hola y bienvenidos a este especial de
noticias con motivo de las sentencias
contra los responsables de los ataques
de noviembre de 2015 en parís hace unos
instantes se conoció que es a la apd
island el último sobreviviente de la de
esta célula terrorista fue condenado a
cadena perpetua tras ser declarado
culpable de asesinato e intento de
asesinato entre otros cargos un evento
que dejó 130 personas muertas vamos a
ampliar esta noticia desde parís con
nuestra periodista dedicado la barrilla
y quien le ha seguido la pista a este
caso de erica muy buenas tardes
cuéntenos cuál fue la sentencia completa
si andrés buenas tardes cosas que
destacan de esta sentencia cuya lectura
aún no ha terminado de la verdad pero
clásicas 50 minutos de lectura por el
presidente de sociales hay que decir que
lo más importante efectivamente ese
recuento nos cargó 4 al 19 de los 30
estados sólo uno de ellos son
considerados como no perteneciente a una
organización terrorista sino que también
actuaba como una organización para
conseguir esta fase sino cenard island
es como usted decía esto será útil para
todos los cargos de pertenencia esta
actuación para cometer atentados como
cómplices de todo lo que ocurrió y se
precia de noviembre y la corte acepta el
requerimiento del misterio público de
una cadena perpetua irreductible una
pena realmente excepcional en el derecho
y en la historia de la justicia francesa
para mohamed de abril dicho amigo de la
infancia el hombre del prometer o aquel
que egipto las imágenes del atentado
generado por eso de indígenas del año
2016 también sé
la pena que había pedido en mi públicas
tesis cadena perpetua con una seguridad
del dios tanto si se puede demandar
algún beneficio carcelario y si no tres
de las otras cadenas perpetuas de
aquellos que eran considerados miembros
de la célula yihadista han sido
producidos a 30 años al de cáncer
justamente si en muchos casos estaban
condenados nos había solicitado cadena
perpetua con un período de
obligatoriedad de 30 años pues
finalmente la corte ha adquirido ha
decidido hacer caso a esa mejora este
tiempo que había solicitado la fiscalía
y darle 30 años a esos tres otros
acusados y sino aquellos que eran
conocidos como las tres pequeñas manos
que firman aquellos que comparecían
libres la corte les ha dado como condena
la que había solicitado el ministerio
público no hubo ninguna rebaja para
ellos aquellos que son condenados a 30
años voy a recordar su nombre son
mohamed tocan kalish osama creyente y
social
erika muchas gracias por ese reporte
desde parís más adelante volveremos con
usted para ampliar esta cobertura y para
entender la importancia de este juicio
vamos a hacer un repaso de los
acontecimientos tal como se
desarrollaron aquella noche del 13 de
noviembre de 2015 cuando tres comandos
terroristas atacaron parís los atentados
incluyeron operaciones suicidas disparos
indiscriminados y toma de rehenes
130 personas perdieron la vida y otras
cientos resultaron heridas
el viernes 13 de noviembre de 2015 una
noche de horror acaba de comenzar el
primer atentado tuvo lugar a las afueras
del estadio nacional de francia cuando
dos terroristas suicidas se inmolaron
con 10 minutos de diferencia un tercer
ataque suicida tuvo lugar menos de media
hora después el presidente françois
hollande que se encontraba en el estadio
en el que se disputaba un partido
amistoso contra alemania fue puesto a
salvo al mismo tiempo se producían más
ataques en el centro de la capital
francesa hombres armados dispararon a
los comensales de un café y un
restaurante de la calle aliviar en el
distrito 10
[Música]
minutos después abrieron fuego en la
calle fontana y en la calle en el
distrito 11
había sangre por todas partes la gente
caía como moscas era una verdadera
escena de guerra me sentía como en las
trincheras
pero el peor ataque de la noche comenzó
cuando tres terroristas interrumpieron
en la sala de conciertos bataclán y
abrieron fuego con armas automáticas
tenían como blanco 1500 personas que
asistían a un concierto de rock
un periodista de lemont que vivía al
lado firmo a algunos de los asistentes
al concierto escapando por una puerta
trasera y a otros colgando de las
ventanas intentando desesperadamente
salir algunos de los que estaban
atrapados dentro se escondieron donde
pudieron
dos policías llegaron y mataron a uno de
los terroristas en la planta baja otros
dos estaban arriba habían tomado rehenes
las fuerzas especiales de la policía
francesa ingresaron aseguraron la planta
baja y los rehenes salieron
y
estábamos todos tirados en el piso y vi
que disparaban por todas partes sentí un
instinto de supervivencia estábamos
todos en el suelo nadie se movía nos
tumbamos lo más bajo posible para que no
nos vieran o para conjugar los riesgos
por con guille a toda la gente se acostó
encima de los demás disparaban
kalashnikovs como si estuvieran
torturando a la gente se disparaba
contra la gente era una carnicería una
carnicería había muertos por todas
partes
y para mí
el presidente francés se dirigió a la
nación justo antes de la medianoche
compatriota
shakespeare
conciudadanos mientras hablo se están
produciendo atentados terroristas de una
magnitud sin precedentes en parís varias
decenas de personas han muerto y muchas
han resultado heridas es un horror
y digamos cumbres
soy un ogro tras intentar negociar con
ellos las fuerzas francesas asaltaron a
los dos terroristas que tenían como
rehenes a los asistentes al concierto la
operación terminó veintiún minutos
después de la medianoche después de tres
horas de derramamiento de sangre fueron
los atentados más mortíferos en francia
desde la segunda guerra mundial
y para analizar esta noticia nos
acompaña desde madrid españa fernando
coche les analista de inteligencia y
riesgos a la seguridad nacional experto
en terrorismo y crímenes de odio señor
coche bienvenido france24 le preguntamos
qué significa este veredicto para
francia en general un país que ha sido
golpeado por tantos atentados
terroristas durante los últimos años
buenas noches desde españa
significa que la justicia francesa ha
optado por la línea dura por la línea de
no rebajar un concepto y hacer una
visión navegantes de los siguientes
intentos de destrucción ar
a parís a francia significa que francia
se alinea con las posiciones menos
continentales el derecho procesal
derecho penal y se alinea con las
corrientes más anglosajonas que optan
por penas más duras y no reinsertables
en la sociedad se está hablando de
condenas perpetuas que no se pueden
reducir pero se pueden evaluar hasta
donde pueden ser obtenidos beneficios
penitenciarios porque hasta este momento
no se utilizaban en francia desde la
xunta guerra mundial incluso en la época
de los años 60 64 85 por el prueba de la
oas también se hicieron penas luego
fueron reducidas a pesar de que eran
mientras terroristas también estamos
ante una sentencia sin precedentes se ha
visto veredictos iguales para o contra
otros terroristas en el mundo
ha habido sentencias parecidas a ésta
pero no de una
profundidad y de una contundencia en el
que él
el ministerio fiscal siempre suele pedir
algo y se les puede conceder casi todo
pero no todo en este caso los tribunales
han concedido la totalidad de lo que ha
pedido
la fiscalía y por tanto no hay
precedentes como tal ante tal número de
delitos tanto el número de personas que
han declarado y que han generado pues
una verdad conmoción que hoy por hoy
sigue durando en francia hay más de 2500
personas que sigue el tratamiento
psicológico psiquiátrico en francia por
acciones indirectas no personas que
vivieran y estarán tres o sentados sino
por los efectos de las personas que
conocían por tanto es hablando de una
situación no sólo sin precedentes sino
que va a sentar un precedente en el
futuro las relaciones con los grupos
terroristas y aquellos que intenten
atentar contra la seguridad ciudadana
será un precedente también para el resto
de los países europeos
es un precedente para países europeos
durante ayudado desde españa será un
precedente en el que se endurecerá ya de
por sí dura sentencia penal contra el
terrorismo que hay en españa y cierra
totalmente cualquier tipo de resquicio a
la visión menos
digamos menos dura la visión más
socializante lo que son este grupo de
terroristas se considera el terrorista
ya no es un delincuente como se
consideraba antes de la legislación la
persona descarriada que puede ser
reinsertado al cabo de un tiempo y le
considera la persona que atenta contra
el estado contra sus fundamentos y que
intenta la subversión del estado
entonces en los países anglosajones se
condena para pena de muerte o la cadena
perpetua revisable y además en
condiciones muy duras de régimen muy
duro ver en la cárcel ahora demuestra
francia con este veredicto su
efectividad en la lucha contra el
terrorismo
demuestra su firmeza e lucha
antiterrorismo francia es un país que
está golpeado y ha sido golpeado en
mucho tiempo por acciones sino
terroristas y desestabilización por
parte de grupos radicales
pero con esta sentencia lo que hace es
alinearse totalmente y dar un paso al
frente en lo que digamos poner pie en
pared lo que digamos que sería lo que a
partir de ahora puede ocurrir como avisa
a navegantes si alguien intenta
subvertir el sistema constitucional de
parís y por tanto se alinea con países
como españa por supuesto que está en
europea como gran bretaña que menos ha
sufrido en países anglosajones ahora
sólo falta que el tribunal penal alemán
por ejemplo el danés y el piel y el
holandés se unan a este tipo de
sentencias para llegar a una unidad una
plataforma unitaria continental sólo
para llegar a países nórdicos que ya
también se plantean con sentados de su
cuello en su momento por un radicalista
de extrema derecha superó la pista que
hizo un atentado contra unos jóvenes el
proceso del demócrata está planteado ya
también la cadena perpetua revisable y
qué en condiciones de aislamiento
penitenciario por tanto nos dirigimos a
europa en general y el mundo también
hacia posiciones cada vez más radicales
el tratamiento de esta gente ahora que
lecciones se aprenden de este mega
juicio una maratón judicial como se
llamó y sólo por mencionar algunos datos
participaron 2500 partes civiles 330
abogados 20 acusados y 5 magistrados
si el procedimiento administrativo el
proceso penal presentó judicial el
encauzamiento en europa es muy laborioso
es muy largo se requieren mucho mucha
documentación mucho el peso procesal
pero eso también tiene una ventaja y es
que se dejan las fisuras totalmente
cerradas y no hay posibilidades de una
apelación porque está procesalmente muy
bien cerrado por tanto digamos que
francia da un paso al frente de nuevo
también en todo lo que significa la
modificación de legislación contra el
terrorismo pero solo con el terrorismo
del régil islámico o cualquier acción
que pretende subvertir el estado bien
señor coche vamos ahora a pasar
nuevamente a parís con nuestra
periodista erika olavarría quien ha
realizado este cubrimiento desde
tempranas horas de la mañana erika muy
buenas tardes cuéntenos cuáles son las
penas de los principales acusados
sí buenas tardes andrés yo creo que lo
más importante a retener primero es esa
cadena perpetua irreductible para sala
de slam el único sobreviviente de los
atentados del 13 de noviembre y esas
tres cadenas perpetuas que fueron
multadas en penas de 30 años de decisión
que son a todos esos miembros de la
célula terrorista considerados miembros
de la célula terrorista y miembros
activos que ayudaron a buscar los
escondites que se encontraron con el que
viajaron a siria me refiero
concretamente a osama que ayer mohamed
bakali y sofía nayarit que son
condenados a 30 años y no a cadena
perpetua recordemos que para ellos el
ministerio público había pedido cadena
perpetua con una obligación de
cumplimiento de penas de 30 años pues se
las ha dejado finalmente en 30 años de
prisión obviamente ellos todos incluidos
podrán apelar estas penas y
eventualmente reducirlas hay que decir
que las tres personas que comparecían de
manera libre en este proceso seguirán
libres y bueno tendrán que ajustar sus
penas a lo que hoy les ha dado el
ministerio público que en la mayoría de
los casos a penas menores de las que se
les había pedido desde el ministerio
público
erika que otras generalidades podemos
decir de este juicio
bueno hoy es un día muy importante no
esto va a marcar la historia de este
país de esta ciudad además esta lentitud
que ha tenido el juez y en general la
corte de entregar este veredicto
obviamente ha marcado a muchas personas
2500 partes civiles que estaban
angustiadas esperando lo que iba a decir
este juez nos lo había recordado más
temprano una abogada este es un caso
excepcional porque las penas son
excepcionales en general en el derecho
francés la cadena perpetua es casi un
símbolo y en el derecho europeo existe
esta pena pero nunca se aplica solamente
en este caso llama la atención porque en
diez situaciones se había solicitado por
lo tanto es un caso que también va a
marcar la historia del derecho francés
aquí todavía hay mucha expectativa en
esta plaza del fin que se encuentra
detrás de la corte es una mezcla entre
personas que están de vacaciones
disfrutando del verano y las víctimas la
prensa y los abogados que están
intentando de analizar lo que ha sido
este veredicto leído en 50 minutos por
el presidente de la corte un texto mucho
más largo pero él dijo que nos iba a
ahorrar no es cierto el tiempo ya que la
espera
ha sido bastante larga
bien erika gracias por este reporte más
adelante volveremos con usted para
seguir actualizando la información y es
que este es un veredicto que llega tras
un maratónico proceso por los atentados
del 13 de noviembre de 2015 como lo
decíamos donde 130 personas perdieron la
vida y cientos resultaron heridas los
fiscales a cargo de la investigación
pidieron frente a la corte penas de
entre 5 hasta 30 años de cárcel para los
acusados y sólo una cadena perpetua sin
libertad condicional para salir abdeslam
el único sobreviviente de los comandos
que efectuaron los ataques esa noche en
este proceso hay muchas historias de
extranjeros que prácticamente se han
mudado a francia mientras se desarrolla
el juicio como la de nancy una chilena
que perdió a su hijo luís felipe en la
sala de conciertos del bataclán la
historia es de erika olavarria
dos días después de iniciado el proceso
el pasado 8 de septiembre financia esta
chilena que perdió a su hijo luís felipe
en la sala de conciertos bataclán
aterrizaba en parís
no tenía abogado tampoco se había
constituido en parte el civil y ni
siquiera tenía unas vacunas reconocidas
por francia pero sabía que quería estar
presente
en estos meses nancy consiguió un
abogado que hable español pero también
se armó toda una vida en parís con lado
nicolás este hotel que paga el estado
francés se ha convertido en su casa
esta gente me ha cogido súper bien bueno
tanto tiempo que permaneció acá pero han
sido para mí súper súper súper
acogedores y les pille el eje estoy en
el proceso por lo tanto
necesito permanecer en un lugar mucho
tiempo y bueno me preguntaron por qué
que siguió entonces yo empecé a explicar
y ellos tienen estos estos estos
atentados muy en la retina
y todos fueron muy afectados por esto
en el escritorio de la pequeña
habitación revistas y libros que hablan
de este proceso fuera de lo común son un
regalo de un policía su intérprete o la
madre de otra de las víctimas he tenido
mucha mucha información
respecto a cómo pasó en el bataclán como
entran en el bataclán yo me imagino como
ya mi hijo
horrible cada día de forma religiosa a
nancy así está el proceso solo faltó en
febrero cuando regresó a chile para
conocer a su nieto pero también porque
necesitaba urgentemente hacer una pausa
en la recta final la chilena considera
que las penas que pidieron los fiscales
no son lo suficientemente severas luego
venía con nuestras expectativas que
estos tipos no salieran nunca más de la
cárcel que
porque todo para mí todos son
uno en mayor o menor medida pero todos
contribuyeron para que todo esto pasara
tras cada audiencia la carga se alivian
en parte gracias a la conversación con
otros familiares en el patio de la corte
nancy tiene ahora más información que
cuando llegó aunque muchas dudas no han
sido resueltas
volvemos con nuestro analista fernando
coche o analista de inteligencia y
riesgos de seguridad nacional le
pregunto ahora qué cambia un juicio así
para un país y para su población ya
habíamos visto en 2007 el juicio de los
atentados de madrid de 2004 los más
mortíferos que conoció europa hasta
ahora se pueden comparar
se pueden comparar desde el punto de
vista técnico y el punto de vista del
impacto social evidentemente aunque sólo
un poco
burdo entre 300 y 150 el impacto no es
tan relevante más que para las víctimas
para el estado sigue siendo un impacto
terrible y se acercan las posturas
procesales escuchando la conversación
que ustedes mantenían con su
corresponsal hablaban de que esas penas
que han puesto a los no directamente
implicados pero sí coadyuvantes el
atentado podrían ser revisadas y podrían
ser minimizadas porque realmente eran 30
años de cumplimiento efectivo de condena
el derecho procesal francés es
extremadamente riguroso yo creo que en
estas operaciones que tienen su derecho
a hacer van a fracasar porque él
seguramente el estado no les va a
permitir el abandono de las cárceles ni
mucho menos va a seguir duro y que hemos
aprendido hemos aprendido a que no se
puede responder con buenismo a gente que
no entiende los principios democráticos
y que su objetivo fundamental es
deconstruir todas gracias y eliminar
subvertir el sistema de valores
constitucionales de este caso de francia
o en españa en su momento y esto es una
corriente que arrastra toda europa
esperemos no llegar a tener que utilizar
el derecho penal del enemigo porque
sería ya pasar ciertas fronteras incluso
para los constitucionalistas y
periodistas españoles franceses
italianos sería volver al siglo 18
entonces esperemos nos llegará a ello
pero el camino está marcado el camino es
de dureza el camino de firmeza el camino
es de no vuelta atrás en el camino
vuelta atrás para las visiones sobre lo
que puede ocurrir cuando una persona
intenta hacer un estado terrorista eso
también tiene un problema y es que ahora
los terroristas están mucho más
concienciados de que una vez que hacer
atentado terroristas tienen que triunfar
porque perder significa ir a ser toda la
vida en la cárcel y ser un ejemplo de la
disciplina jurídica de europa es decir
que podríamos afirmar que este tipo de
medidas que se adoptaron hoy son
suficientes son las adecuadas
son suficiente el punto vista penal y el
punto vista administrativo del budista
procesal seguramente no son suficientes
nunca es suficiente para los que han
sufrido la pérdida de un familiar y
nunca suficiente para restañar las
heridas que ha generado esta disrupción
en el estado de derecho son suficientes
probablemente sí porque son penas en las
que no hay
reinserción posible no hay distribución
de la condena por tanto son penas
efectivas que son equivalentes a una
condena perfecto de una persona que
tenga 30 años termina la condena con 60
años de actividad tiene por ciudad
reinserción social y lo más probable es
que acabe en lugares de beneficiencia y
la gente que comete algún otro delito
dentro de la prisión seguirá aumentando
a esa condena a esa condena los años de
cárcel por tanto nos acercamos hacia
modelos como por ejemplo en eeuu en el
que la segunda implicación en un delito
lleva consigo la pena de casi con cadena
perpetua o difícil redención por tanto
significa mucho dedica mucho hay que
estudiarla
a la sentencia en profundidad y ver qué
es lo que ha cambiado el derecho
procesal francés es administrativa
derecho penal para conseguir saber hasta
qué punto está implicado a un cambio
jurídico en la doctrina francesa ha
quedado tenía continental que más priva
en europa bien y es que este histórico
proceso judicial también ha sido el
mayor juicio penal de la historia de
francia que se celebra en la mayor sala
construida en el país ya que los
acusados son juzgados por varios delitos
veamos el informe
un total de 20 hombres son sospechosos
de desempeñar papeles clave en los
atentados terroristas de noviembre de
2015 en parís 14 de ellos están en el
banquillo de los acusados 14 de los
hombres supervivientes fueron juzgados
en la sala especial penal de parís por
su participación la noche del 13 de
noviembre entre ellos el único
superviviente de las tres bandas
yihadistas que protagonizaron los
atentados en todo parís sala abdeslam
hombres de entre 28 y 39 años entre
ellos el amigo de la infancia de
abdeslam mohamed a berlín y apodado el
hombre del sombrero abril y fue acusado
de haber proporcionado armas y apoyo
logístico durante los atentados de
noviembre antes de huir a bélgica donde
decidió a último momento no inmolarse
durante los atentados de marzo de 2016
en bruselas estos acusados fueron
procesados por varios delitos entre
ellos
participación en una organización
terrorista complicidad en asesinato
complicidad en tentativa de asesinato
complicidad en tentativa de asesinato de
personas que ocupan cargos de autoridad
pública el fiscal ha pedido cadena
perpetua completa para
una pena que sólo se ha impuesto cuatro
veces en francia desde 2007 para abril y
los fiscales han pedido la cadena
perpetua con un mínimo de 22 años de
prisión se pidieron penas más leves de 5
años de prisión para los acusados de
haber ayudado a abdeslam a escapar y
seis hombres fueron juzgados en ausencia
de ellos se cree que cinco están muertos
entre ellos se usa matar considerado uno
de los arquitectos de la masacre así
como los miembros del estado islámico
fabián y jean-michel tran la duración
del juicio y el número de demandantes lo
han convertido en el caso judicial más
impactante de la historia de francia
bien volvemos a parís con nuestra
periodista erika olavarría erika cuál
fue el ambiente durante la lectura del
veredicto
bueno hay que decir que todo el mundo
toda la gente que estaba esperando
tantas horas había un poco de esa
cooperación y finalmente cuando fue la
lectura había mucha concentración a
salas de slam estaba vistiendo una
camiseta negra sentado como siempre en
la posición de ese box de seguridad la
más cercana al presidente de la corte
los acusados escucharon tranquilamente
la lectura de este veredicto así como
las partes civiles y también a la prensa
lo que son las reacciones mismas no
hemos podido todavía porque tuvimos que
venir rápidamente a instalarnos aquí
pero obviamente el ambiente era de mucha
atención y tensión para ver cuáles de
las penas iban a ser finalmente
aceptadas por la corte sobre todo había
duda con respecto a las cadenas
perpetuas y bueno finalmente se confirmó
la de sala de slam y la de mohamed
abrines que justamente eran los dos
principales acusados en este caso y
arica la preguntó cuáles fueron los
momentos más fuertes durante este juicio
durante estos meses
un juicio exactamente son diez meses de
juicio hubo muchos momentos fuertes
empezando por esos primeros días de
proceso en que recordemos a la dslam
hablaba había pasado año sin hablar
durante su detención en bélgica y se
decidía a hablar y se reconocía como un
soldado del grupo estado islámico esto
vaticinaba realmente un juicio muy
polémico y complicado sin embargo él
mismo lo reconocía ayer y en ese en eso
consiste el mérito de sus abogados
lograron cambiar su actitud cada vez que
pasaba el tiempo él fue colaborando cada
vez más con la justicia e insistiendo en
ese arrepentimiento justamente quiero
remarcar eso porque una de las cosas que
no retuvo la corte fue que él no hubiera
accionado su cinturón de seguridad en
ese atentado que él debía realizar
porque se había arrepentido era uno de
los argumentos a favor de su cliente de
los abogados de sala de lan sin embargo
la corte consideró que finalmente este
cinturón no había funcionado porque
estaba en estado así que ese momento
fuerte fue muy importante luego también
hubo un momento en que los abogados de
la defensa de todos los acusados
salieron esto ocurrió en marzo y fue
porque sala de lan comenzó a decir que
su vida con este juicio no es cierto se
había visto destruida las partes civiles
comenzaron a aplaudir como riéndose de
esta persona que estaba haciéndose la
víctima cuando ellos sí que saben lo que
es el sufrimiento entonces los abogados
de los acusados le pidieron al
presidente de la corte que suspendiera
esta audiencia sin embargo él no lo hizo
les cortó además el micrófono a los
abogados de la defensa que salieron
todos juntos al unísono de esta gran
sala del proceso en general otra cosa
que vamos a retener que va a quedar en
la memoria de los parisinos y de francia
son los testimonios tan duros de las
partes civiles al comienzo uno pensaba
por ejemplo como periodista con lo
difícil que es encontrar un testimonio
en situaciones como esta que iba a ser
difícil tener justamente esos relatos
aquí en la corte pero hemos visto que
este proceso ha servido para las
víctimas sobre todo para los
sobrevivientes como un bálsamo como una
catarsis en que se sienten todos que
tienen finalmente una historia y hubo
historias muy terribles que era muy
difícil de oír a veces incluso uno
quería salir de la sala para no seguir
escuchando esto y pensar que esto no
existe realmente la realidad otra cosa
importante bueno se vivieron una
elección presidencial y unas elecciones
legislativas mientras este proceso se
llevaba a cabo y también el kobe y
recordemos que todos los acusados fueron
cayendo finalmente y eso justamente fue
lo que retrasó este proceso el veredicto
debía ser entregado hace un mes y
finalmente lo tenemos hoy también se
puede considerar como un momento fuerte
la visita de un ex presidente de la
república aunque la defensa de los
acusados la ha criticado en todo momento
dicen que eso ha hizo que este proceso
fuera más bien un proceso político y no
un proceso de justicia y finalmente
bueno esas excusas que digo sal abdeslam
a los familiares de las víctimas
recordemos que él dijo a través de su
abogada y luego él personalmente que se
había puesto casi en la piel de esas
víctimas que él había muchas cosas que
desconocía de lo que había sido la
preparación de estos ataques porque él
básicamente explica que llegó aquí casi
por accidente por qué
a último minuto y bueno él dice haber
aprendido mucho de las víctimas y haber
entendido también su dolor y se dirigió
a ellas directamente pidiéndoles
disculpas y también el testimonio de
sonia una mujer que en realidad no se
llama si ella es una testigo clave fue
una persona que denunció a los cerebros
de la mitad a paul que había organizado
los ataques y que recordemos estaba
escondido en un departamento en sant
dennis al norte de parís fue ella la que
tuvo la valentía de denunciarlos se dio
cuenta de que en realidad no eran unas
personas que le habían pedido un favor
de alojarlos sino que eran terroristas
que estaban que continuaban planeando
ataques y ella los llamó los llama la
policía perdón denunció y fue lo que
desencadenó la explosión finalmente de
ese departamento cuando los terroristas
se hicieron explotar ella hoy vive con
una identidad diferente no se sabe
únicamente dónde vive y el dio su
testimonio obviamente con su imagen
difusa para no poder reconocerla y con
una voz también
distorsionada para que no se le pudiera
identificar sin duda considerada por las
víctimas civiles como una heroína
enrique ahora una de las grandes
preguntas es cierra esto la herida
abierta que tuvo francia durante estos
años
es complicado es complicado pero como yo
les mencionaba yo creo que por lo menos
para las víctimas ha sido muy importante
la verdad que al comienzo este proceso
se preguntaba tiene sentido esto hoy por
ejemplo ya hablaba con el señor de un
taxi un chófer de taxi me decía pero por
fin se acaba esto porque no solamente
para muchas personas les da un poco de
miedo porque esto podía volver a abrir
la herida pero yo creo que efectivamente
la herida nunca había cerrado y este
proceso por lo menos ha permitido sacar
afuera todo lo que había tratar de
entender porque se produjo esto yo
siempre he hablado con el padre de una
víctima chilena y él siempre me pregunta
a mí no me interesa saber quién
quien dio muerte a quien a mí lo que me
interesa saber es por qué
se genera este odio porque alguien hace
esto dónde está la raíz del mar y yo
creo que gracias a los testimonios que
hubo de muchos especialistas en
terrorismo a abogados policías quizás
esas preguntas han sido resueltas para
algunas de las partes civiles y quizás
eso puede entregar paz a ustedes
mostraban el testimonio de nancy la
chilena también ella ella me decía al
comienzo de este juicio yo necesitaba
venir porque se lo debo a mi hijo yo
pienso que ella obviamente la pena nunca
a nadie se la va a quitar de no tener a
su hijo pero al menos va a sentir que
ella pudo hacer algo por él y se los
digo y me emociono también perdón porque
como parisina y como persona que vive en
francia obviamente que estos atentados
nos tocaron a todos y quería decir en
ese sentido una cosa que se me olvidó
que también fue un momento muy fuerte de
este juicio que cuando se escucharon las
grabaciones y se vieron algunos vídeos
muy cortos pero sobre todo grabaciones
sonoras de lo que pasaba en el bataclán
cuando se escuchan los tiros de los
terroristas que dispararon de forma
indiscriminada justamente nancy me decía
que su intérprete una chica ecuatoriana
le había dicho esto te va a ser mal dijo
no yo necesito escucharlo yo quiero
saber cómo murió mi hijo y es entendible
erika que esté emocionado teniendo en
cuenta que fue un proceso horroroso
además doloroso muchas gracias por este
informe más adelante volveremos con
usted para seguir actualizando esta
noticia volvemos entonces con fernando
corcho desde madrid y hablamos ahora de
seguridad en francia fernando que cambio
para el país el 13 de noviembre en
cuanto a protección y fuerzas de
inteligencia
en cambio todo cambió todo francia
habitualmente no compartía información
mucho menos de raíces islamistas que
obtenía de sus fuentes de información en
el magreb no compartía de información
como la que tenía que compartir estos
dos pasos también en españa cuando
francia no compartía información con
grupos del grupo terrorista eta que
durante tantos años durante más de 40
años ha mortificado a mi país y ha
cambiado todo porque ahora se sabe que
la única forma de compatible este tipo
de terror es la cooperación la
cooperación y la unidad internacional en
temas de seguridad e inteligencia donde
las recelos
donde los los egos donde las necesidades
de colgarse medallas quedan en un
segundo plano lo importante es la
detención y el procesamiento de esta
gente incluso antes de que pueda cometer
un atentado ha cambiado todo se ha
reforzado la seguridad se ha modificado
los procedimientos de protocolos de
seguridad en temas de
intervención policial se ha endurecido
muchísimo las acciones de la policía en
temas que puedan ser origen de
terrorismo o de conflictos armados y
sobre todo ha cambiado
la percepción de lo que es la seguridad
francés era un país seguro para algún
tipo de altercado pero nos miraban sobre
toda españa con una mirada de
superioridad diciendo que eso jamás
podría pasar en una sociedad tan
avanzada y tan controlada y tan
centralizada como en francia y el terror
alcanza a todos en todas partes del
mundo y cada vez más por tanto a una
amenaza global sólo se puede responder
una cooperación igual creo que esa
percepción de seguridad que usted
mencionaba sigue estando vigente ahora
en francia hoy en día
una vez que sufres atentado y lo digo
como español una vez que sufres
atentados en tu tierra y ves
sistemáticamente a españa muy
frecuentemente hubo años en los que
diariamente morían 345 policías o
miembros pero por segura del estado
militares etcétera pues es muy difícil
apreciar de seguridad a pesar de ser
países muy seguros ha cambiado
totalmente en francia ya no se sienten
vulnerables como otros países también y
ahora miran hacia países que hemos
sufrido el terrorismo para que les entre
comillas por favor entiendan les
aconsejamos en cómo cerrar esas heridas
en cómo mejorar el rendimiento de la
policía y cómo conseguir convencer a la
población es una parte muy importante de
la detención y la elaboración de
información para evitar que esos
atentados se vuelvan a repetir y eso lo
han aprendido muy rápido muy bien y lo
han ejecutado de manera excepcional ha
cambiado mucho y va a cambiar también
mucho más porque lamentablemente todos
los informes todas las perspectivas nos
dicen esto es un proceso que va a
ocurrir más veces
esperemos no de esta forma pero van a
ocurrir de hecho en españa es el país
del mundo que más detenciones de
yihadistas previos a cometer atentados
hay
y unas 400 personas al mes al año se
detiene en españa con vínculos
yihadistas con vínculos que intentan
atentar en francia en alemania en
cualquier parte de europa y sobre todo
en españa el propósito de esta
advertencia que usted hace cuál es el
riesgo terrorista para francia hoy no
solo para francia sino también para
europa
el mismo riesgo que era hace un mes dos
meses seis meses o un año
ahora bien evidentemente la
profesionalización no suene así de
burgos la profesionalización de los
terroristas la concienciación de los
terroristas cada vez es mayor antes eran
gente que no sabía seguramente a lo que
iba a hacer seguramente lo había
idealizado fruto de la propaganda
yihadista y que no se encontraban en
condiciones de una dureza emocional o
una preparación emocional como ahora sí
ya lo están ahora ya hemos visto que la
gente cada vez se mete en estos vínculos
ya no lo hace una manera tan naif sino
lo hace de una manera mucho más
concienciada y eso es un riesgo mayor
progreso mayor para las fuerzas toda esa
seguridad del estado en sobre su mayor
para para los países y sobre todo
a partir de ahora nos tenemos que dar
cuenta de que el riesgo no sólo está en
nuestras casas el hecho también está en
los países de origen si no se ayuda a
los países de origen a detectar a
controlar y así evitar la subversión de
los valores democráticos entonces
seguirá siendo una fuente de captación
una fuente de peregrinación para atentar
contra los europeos en este caso pero
dando como evaluar las medidas que ha
tomado francia contra el terrorismo
durante los últimos años debido a los
ataques que ha sufrido
excelentemente han tomado medidas muy
buenas de cooperación básicamente de
precio internacional han formado a sus
policías en cosas que ellos pensaban que
iban a ocurrir les adoptado de formación
de capacitación en temas de
interrogatorio y sobre todo ante la
detección de pistas de indicadores de
radicalización islámica y de
organización religiosa e ideológica
también y por supuesto el impacto en la
policía y en todo lo que tiene que ver
con el aparato del sistema francés ha
tomado una concienciación mucho más
cercana de lo que significa el
terrorismo en el domicilio ya no
hablamos de lobos solitarios hablamos de
una estructura
qué pretende generar lo que se llama
guerra asimétrica guerra híbrida la
guerra por otros medios pueden no tener
explosivos pueden obtener armas de fuego
pero les basta un cuchillo como de
ocurrir muchas veces les basta un
martillo les basta que en cualquier
lugar del mundo se siembre el terror y
eso la policía francesa lo aprendido
para aprender los indicadores para
romper cualquier tipo de captación en el
territorio nacional en este caso en
francia y romper cualquier tipo de
adoctrinamiento que se pueda generar
como se hace habitualmente las escuelas
o en los centros de formación
profesional o de negocios de los países
eso es lo que han aprendido he aprendido
muy rápido y he aprendido muy
eficientemente a cumplir los objetivos
de una sociedad la medida de lo posible
segura porque la seguridad total no
existe
fernando citaba a erika a nuestra
periodista la pregunta que la hacía un
familiar de las víctimas cuando ya lo
entrevistó y es por qué se genera este
odio cuál cree que ha sido el detonante
de este tipo de ataques en europa
pregunta excelente y pregunta contestada
de responder el no hay un detonante
único para este odio hay una consecución
de la asimilación de una narrativa por
parte de estas personas estos individuos
que realmente creen en lo que se está
diciendo no tienen una confrontación con
la realidad no tienen un sistema en el
que puedan evaluar lo que se está
preguntando porque está adoctrinando
porque se está enseñando ni tampoco se
ponen en duda en la cosificación de las
sociedades occidentales de la visión
como del demonio para entendernos los
que la sociedad occidental y de que está
intentando eliminar al islam enviando a
todas las sociedades musulmanas entonces
la gente
que sufre este adoctrinamiento
no no no es consciente o no era
consciente de qué es lo que estaba
ocurriendo y el odio viene precisamente
de la inconsciencia muchas veces en
españa hemos vivido que cuando algunos
terroristas cometieron acciones
terroristas a pesar de ser concienciados
durante dos semanas se les tenía
aislados por parte de sus compañeros
para seguir adoctrinando les y para
evitar cualquier tipo de remordimiento
en la acción terrorista y eso es algo
muy importante porque cuando uno
desarticular y ve no en una película
sino ven de verdad los resultados los
efectos de algo que ha provocado uno
mismo es el asesinato de un ser humano
entonces la conciencia puede cambiar y
entonces a partir de ahí triunfaría la
democracia de tremor triunfaría la
libertad y los derechos constitucionales
es complejo el odio siempre va a estar
el odio al techo de cristal el odio alan
olvera de la integración el odio a la
separación por etnia color religión
ideología el odio siempre va a estar
pero cuando ponemos herramientas que
disuelvan ese odio de manera efectiva
con formación con capacitación con leyes
justas y equitativas leyes que equiparen
a los hemos de así inmigrantes de
segunda generación a los nacionales que
siempre son todos nacionales pero bueno
para entendernos pues entonces se le
quitará armas a ese odio pero nunca
desaparecerá porque siempre habrá
fanáticos que siempre vean en el otro la
culpa de los problemas que tienen que
recule paran al otro de los problemas
que tiene su país su religión o su
sociedad y siempre habrá gente que sea
adoptable y gente que quiere adoctrinar
señor corcho vamos a volver ahora con
nuestra periodista erika la barrida
quien se encuentra en este momento con
el abogado de una de las asociaciones de
víctimas del terrorismo erika muy buenas
tardes cuéntenos
sí buenas tardes se trata de ella más de
la hace él es abogado de life for paris
una de las asociaciones de las víctimas
del 13 de noviembre y simplemente le
vamos a preguntar a él lo que piensa de
este veredicto
[Música]
e
él dice justo que hubo 10 meses de
proceso y que cada uno tuvo el tiempo de
decir su verdad tanto los acusados como
las víctimas los acusados que por cierto
dice él tenían excelentes abogados que
piensan sus clientes que equipo no sé
dónde
está
él me dice que él no sabe todavía por
qué no se ha juntado con sus clientes
pero piensa que algunos pueden estar
satisfechos otros quizás no tanto pero
en general cree que es una decisión
justa
es un pan que se depende de lo que
se
le preguntó
qué piensa
[Música]
usted
efectivamente él dice que bueno que
obviamente la perpetuidad que más se
retiene es la de salud de lan que es un
símbolo un símbolo porque es una cadena
perpetua que no se puede reducir eso
significa que la vida que el pp saben él
no puede reducir su pena él tendrá que
vivir siempre en prisión una cadena
perpetua real
[Música]
difícil
él dice que este tipo de cadenas se
puede apelar obviamente pero después de
los 30 años pero que va a ser un
recorrido difícil que no va a hacer
apenas se cumplan los 30 años que él
salga libertad que él piensa que va a
ser mucho más tarde en caso de que se
produzca de tu corazón
de todas maneras tiene el derecho a
apelar
[Música]
muchas gracias él dice que efectivamente
no es una decisión que todavía se sepa
que obviamente que es algo que van a
tener que definir los abogados de sala
de lancia apelan a esta sentencia pero
que obviamente él está en derecho a
hacerlo y se cree que contó un apple efe
tú tampoco sea nuevo es verdad que
cuando uno apela habría que hacer un
nuevo proceso es un amigo' postérmino ap
título de moción que servirá
y me di que me dice que efectivamente si
hay un proceso de apelación no será
igual no será un proceso de diez veces
como ahora será mucho más reducido de
dos a tres meses él piensa y que no va a
ser del mismo tipo que un proceso de
apelación no es nunca como un primer
proceso no sé si ustedes quieren
preguntar algo andrés en el estudio
erika lamentablemente se nos acaba el
tiempo pero les agradecemos por este
cubrimiento muchísimas gracias nosotros
seguimos aquí en estudio vamos ahora con
nuestro analista fernando coche ya nos
acercamos a la parte final de este
cubrimiento especial y le pregunto usted
mencionaba que es necesario por ejemplo
la implementación de herramientas que
disuelvan este odio que que son la base
de los atentados cuál serán esas
herramientas o cuáles debería hacer esas
herramientas
antes de responder a la pregunta si
quiero destacar lo que ha hecho el
abogado que es muy importante se han
hecho todas las garantías procesales
todas garantías administrativas a
garantías judiciales para que estos
individuos tengan excelentes abogados se
han cumplido su trabajo y que han
conseguido lo mejor para sus clientes en
este caso la menor pena posible para
muchos de ellos pero las únicas
herramientas que hay es la formación la
capacitación
abrir las mentes a la gente para que no
pueda ser radicalizada la formación la
capacitación en la educación en los
propios colegios los centros escolares
la integración de verdad efectiva no la
mezcla no efectiva y la con la
integración no efectiva sino la que es
realmente una integración de igualdad
roto en un país que no es aconfesional
que es un país laico por tanto por
constitución por tanto existe la
igualdad la fraternidad y la libertad es
la única manera de conseguir que esto se
reduzca eliminarse nunca nunca porque
vienen desde origen el miedo el odio
viene desde origen y a veces escala en
personas en este caso sí bueno llegamos
al final de este cubrimiento especial
tal como se esperaba fue condenado a
cadena perpetua sale abdeslam el único
sobreviviente de la célula terrorista
que perpetró los atentados de noviembre
de 2015 en parís y junto a él otras 18
personas fueron condenadas agradecemos a
fernando coche analista de inteligencia
y riesgos a la seguridad nacional y
también el cubrimiento de nuestra
periodista erika olavarría y por
supuesto todos nuestros televidentes
gracias por acompañarnos continúen con
toda nuestra programación